at this point where you are okay what
what what you're doing fighting are you
still enjoying watching fights are you
still enjoying watching boxing ufc
absolutely you do who do you like
watching i like watching all the fights
i like watching tango like tyson fury i
like him um
and devin haney i like um this young guy
um
steven shakur there's a bunch of little
fighters they need to start fighting
each other now
is there a favorite weight class you
like to watch at this point or it
doesn't matter for you you just like to
see good fights exciting fights you got
it and ufc udl you like watching conor
you like watching
all right well connor's number one yeah
i like them all connor's number one big
fan yeah
you think he's going to make a big
comeback
we normally get injured like that's
tough those are tough injuries
overcome
they continue to come back and you
continue doing the same thing kicking
you have to kick to win if you don't you
have the fear of possibly breaking it
again
so he made a lot of money if it's just
if his money he just do some other stuff
some announcements and some other stuff
he's really advantageous
just be who he is he's gonna always have
something cool to do he's always gonna
have something cool to do yeah i saw him
the other post a picture of a nice lambo
yati bot i don't know if you saw that or
not well i don't know um if that means
he's rich that missed the show they
spend a lot of money
any advice for someone who's starting
because some of our guys are starting to
make a lot of money millions of dollars
but you know they got kids they got
families what advice would you give to
somebody who starts making a lot of
money money they've never made before
there's always some trust funds and
trust funds the organization
from what i learned from all of the
robber barons say the turn of the
century 150 years ago rockefeller
and before then like in saint 1850
there might have been
500 of the families 1900 may have been 2
000 or whatever um
percentage families but now you've seen
that their names they're still the names
of five percent you don't see too many
those old guys may say rockefeller
off-camera but you don't see that now
it's all about um
there's some silicon city money
but you notice only certain what i was
trying to say that um it's an art and
taking care of money because only a few
of those guys that
were robbing barons back in the 1890s
and stuff like that only have a handful
still survive now
so normally the third or second
generation all that billionaire and
their money goes away second third
generation the billionaire money goes
because these guys don't work hard for
they don't understand
the bad guys did you hear what he just
said oh my god you know now these kids
know the value of everything but they
don't know they know the price of
everything we don't know the value of
anything you got to save money not spend
money i used to be you got to spend
money all the time and then i said oh
sick
when i didn't have it i wanted it now i
have it i don't want this
and that's what sometimes people have to
deal with they have to deal with
survivors remorse and all that stuff
everybody knows that she's got shot died
of ods and i made it i'm big time i can
get anybody i want to do anything i want
who the do i think i am
you know
so it comes back to really i'm
submitting to god or to the energy the
universe
definitely that was powerful my
top fight in your opinion
i saw your interview i've seen your
interview with arsenio hall when uh i
think it's is it sugar ray and ali
it's so beautiful that interview the way
what he says about you what you say
about him you can tell there was a very
strong affinity between uh both of you
and uh you know
muhammad ali talking about the fact that
this is the man he doesn't want to fight
and then him saying i wouldn't be
hawaiian without you if you haven't seen
it you got to watch it top five greatest
boxer of all time in your opinion
that's it ali
at the top
so if you like this sort of shortcut
from an interview i did click over here
to watch the entire interview and
please don't forget to subscribe to the
channel take care everybody bye
[Music]
you